we've got some breaking news this
afternoon to serving metropolitan police
officers have been dismissed over
discriminatory discriminatory messages
they sent to colleagues in a WhatsApp
group including some about Katie Price's
disabled Sons a bit more about this um
eight serving and former met police
officers had been found guilty of gross
misconduct over discriminate
discriminatory and offensive messages
that they shared including some about
Miss price disabled son the officers
there were seven men and one woman and
they were found to have sent sexist
racist homophobic transphobic and
disabledist comments in a WhatsApp group
between May of 2016 and June of 2018 so
the latest out of that is that two
serving met police officers have been
dismissed and that is over
discriminatory messages that they sent
to colleagues in that WhatsApp group and
as I said those did include some about
Katie Price's desk disabled son